sensation ausgezeichnet im wahrsten
sinne mit dem renommierten man booker
prize muss man am leben hängen haben wir
das recht zu vegetieren zu sterben
das sind verstörende fragen höchst
verführerisch gestellt von einer ganz
neuen stimme in der literatur der
koreanerin hang kann nun entdeckte der
westen und auch in zürich lauscht das
publikum gebannt ihrer ganz eigenartigen
erzählung für die mancher schon den
vergleich mit kraft hat es passiert ganz
ganz selten dass man etwas ließ bei dem
man das gefühl hat jetzt hat die autorin
oder autor etwas ganz ganz neues gemacht
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo ich bin ich
habe so etwas noch nie gelesen
es ist die geschichte von jung ist die
durchschnittliche frau der welt so
findet ihr mann dean den workaholic
bekocht sie mit deftiger koreanische
küche fleisch lass dich doch über nacht
ohne vorwarnung man alles anders
sie wird zur vegetarierin tintenfisch
schweinebauch von dem fleisch alles
verband sie aus dem kühlschrank protest
ein hilferuf so ahnen die leser doch
ihre familie hört ihr nicht zu ihr vater
will sie zwingen fleisch zu essen doch
jung lehnt sich auf gegen das prinzip
fleisch weigert sich fleisch essen zu
müssen
diese verweigerung ist symbolisch weil
fleisch essen latenz sehr viel gewalt in
sich birgt kam ihrer unschuld zu
bewahren geht sie in die nähe des todes
sie riskiert erleben
es ist eine radikale entschlossenheit
sich aus diesem leben zurück zu ziehen
die junge frau verstummt liefert keine
begründung für ihr verhalten verweist
nur auf die träume die sie immer wieder
heimsuchen
darin erscheint jeder fleischkonsum als
teil ihrer persönlichen gewalt
geschichte und der gewalt geschichte des
menschen
vieles bleibt offen und rätselhaft in
diesem buch das ist teil der faszination
die es auf den leser ausübt
man kann ist auch lyrikerin sehr erzählt
in reduzierter dichter sprache betört
und verstört
wir leben in einer zeit wo es viele
fragen im zusammenhang mit gewalt gibt
was bedeutet das konkret mensch oder
menschlich zu sein
was wollen wir dagegen unternehmen wenn
unsere umwelt unmenschlich ist
ich hoffe dass mein buch dazu führt
darüber nachzudenken
was als verzicht auf fleisch beginnt
wird bald zur radikalen selbstauflösung
yang he verweigert alle menschliche
nahrung
sie ist sicher wie ein baum nur noch
wasser und licht zu benötigen
friss oder stirb vor dieser wahl
gestellt entscheidet sie sich für das
zweite
nur so kann sie wirklich mensch sein ich
meine natürlich nicht dass wir alle
pflanzen werden müssen um nicht
gewalttätig zu sein aber für junge ist
es so sie hat diesen weg gewählt
sie hört tatsächlich auf als mensch so
existiert
man kann's rätselhafte geschichte ist
keine über vegetarismus
es geht um einen menschen der sich
radikal zur selbstbestimmung
durchgerungen hat das buch erzählt von
der sehnsucht sich loszulösen von allem
was ihr menschen meinen sein zu müssen
kommenden sonntag übrigens wird
debattiert bei den sternstunden am
philosophischen stammtisch zum